vous avez jamais pris de vacances jamais
jamais non et vous souhaitez en prendre
oui bien entendu comme tout le monde
tout le monde part en vacan pourquoi que
les agriculteurs ne pourrai pas partir
un peu prendre un peu de
plaisir le mois de juillet est revenu et
avec lui la chaleur les moissons les
gros travaux et puis aussi les
vacanciers toujours plus nombreux plus
libres et sans le vouloir plus
provocquant car pour l'agric qui tourne
toute la journée sur son tracteur c'est
le temps des comparaisons il voudrait
bien pouvoir arrêter sa machine sous un
arbre et aller lui aussi se rafraîchir
dans le lac voisin la tentation des
vacances vient jusqu'à lui dans cette
usine sans porte et sans toit son champ
seulement voilà les congés cette liberté
garantie à date fixe les congés ne sont
pas pour lui lui ne peut pas s'arrêter
même s'il fait très chaud même s'il est
fatigué même s'il est malade
car alors c'est sa femme qui doit
ajouter son travail à sa propre tâche
car une vache un fruit un épis de blé
cela ne se débranche pas comme une
machine outie cette bataille pour la
liberté de partir d'aller voir autre
chose un groupe de familles paysanes de
la région de Besançon essaye de la
gagner l'association a embauchuché un
agriculteur volant un dépanneur en somme
que l'on appelle au secours quand on
veut partir un peu comme on engage une
dactyo intérimaire dans une maison de
commerce le dépanneur c'est Monsieur
Roussel aujourd'hui il s'occupe des
vaches dans cette ferme demain il fera
les foins ailleurs il est devenu salarié
sans quitter pour autant le seul métier
qu'il connaisse il a 4 semaines de
congés payé 850 francs par mois et
finalement jamais de patron pour le
surveiller monsieur Rous ça marche la
traite c'est très bien oui ça va quel
effet ça vous fait de Tra tous les jours
des vaches différentes ça me change pas
beaucoup parce que du j'étais
agriculteur dans le temps ça
pas beauoup pourquoi vous êtes parti de
chez vous la
fopti
[Musique]
Pasin c'est
pas les G
[Musique]
lou
COP vous aimz le travail fait actement
oui pourquoi parce
que
làdans je préfère ça de TR une
usine comme
çaux vaut dans
l'agriculture ce jourl monsieur Rousel
travaillait chez les grands perins car
c'était autour des Grandin de partir un
vieux projet il av ré mais à la campagne
il est difficile de mettre la CL sous
late bien là c'est vrai mais la nature
avait mis son V oui on a fini
mais non encore pas demain oh il y a pas
rentille demain il y a rien à faire non
non bien parce que la Fauch
cé Jam tuen a pas trop fait voir
aujourd'hui non non ça été ah ben c'est
bien alors Monsieur grandp la journée a
été dur oh oui ça va on a l'habitude
force oui vousêtes pas un peu triste
aujourd'hui devrait être en vacances
ouis mais bien obligé c'est le temps qui
n'a pas été oui vous aviez prévu de
partir vous aviez prévu
oui un peu
pour la première fois que j'ai pris le
remplaçant pour essayer pour voir comme
ça voulait aller comme si était habituel
pour l'habituer un peu à la maison parce
que si on part si si on part 8 jours
alors qu'il est tout seul pour TR faire
tout le travail pour l'habituer un peu
pour voir ce que que ça donne ça mais je
crois que ça ça va ça va alors pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas parti cette fois-ci ah
bah pourquoi je suis pas parti parce que
il y a encore des Pointis qui n'étent
encore pas fa fini quoi autrement on
serait parti c'est ça alors vous aviez
tout prévu le départ PRU oui oui et
votre femme aussi est un pe triste oh
oui surtout elle parce que nous comme
elle n'est pas une paysane né tandis que
moi ça me fait pas tout à fait pareil
qu'elle vous avz jamais pris de vacances
jamais jamais et vous souhaitez en
prendre oui bien entendu comme tout le
monde tout le monde part en vacances
pourquoi que les agriculteurs ne pourrai
pas partir un peu prendre un peu de
plaisir pourquoi vous croyez que c'est
important les vacances oh mais ça détend
et puis un peu le souci on laisse soucis
derrière un
peu je sais pas
moi à force c'est comme c'est pas pour ê
c'est que peu pour faire un peu comme
les autres puis enensite de ça pour pas
toujours rester à la maison toujours à
la même place faire toujours le même
travail aller voir un peu s'instruire un
peu ailleurs pour voir ce qu'il fut que
dites on laisse le souci derrière mais
je suis sûr que si vous partiez vous
seriez inquiet non non du tout pas moi
pas moi non d'abord j'ai confiance à au
monsieur Rousel là puisque je l'ai vu
travailler ça va ça va ça très bien bien
mais par exemple vous pourriez pas vous
faire aider par un voisin parti par
exemple oh non c'est impossible ça c'est
pas possible non vous bvez un coup
volontier pourquoi c'est pas possible s
oh non parce que vous savez tout le
monde
a un peu pas technique mais un peu c'est
mode de soigner c'est mode de traire ses
habitudes vous m' dit tout à l'heure que
vos meilleurs copains é des ouvriers
vous enviez le genre de vie des ouvriers
ah non du tout non j'envie pas les
ouvriers non non j'envie pas les ou
puisque je suis né là-dedans mais je me
place pas comme tous les agriculteurs
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont
vraiment pas assz sorti pas assz c'est
pas question sont pas intelligents
mais pas assez sorti
surtout les
ouvriers parlé des ouvriers tout à
l'heure me voir enfermer dans
une dans une usine ce serait je sa pas
moi mettre en prison c'est pas possible
celui qui est né là-dedans c'est pas
possible est ouvrier il y en a qui
arrivent mais je sais avec quel
sacrifice puis ils sont pas bien
heureux aussitôt qu'ils ont un moment
ils vont aider à leur parents ou bien
leurs frères ou bien leur ami quelque
chose autement on voit bien que ça ne
leur plaît pas tellement ils sont
obligés ils sont obligés
quoi la chaîne les cadeaux de travail
l'horloge pointeuse des usines c'est
cela que craignent grand perérin et tant
d'autres agriculteurs pourtant dans un
monde qui ne peut s'enrichir qu'en
s'industrialisant n'est-ce pas ce qui
attend la plupart des 200000 paysans qui
chaque année en France abandonne la
terre il y a 15 ans notre pays comptait
autant d'agriculteurs que d'ouvriers
aujourd'hui il y en a deux fois moins
mais être ouvrier ne signifie pas
forcément vivre en ville et troquer la
fourche contre la manette
dépassant Grenoble nous sommes allés
plus haut en montagne nous devions nous
arrêter à pelle lafolle un petit village
de liser près du lac du sauté là les
terres sont en pente de tout temps le
travail y a été pénible ingrat mais
aujourd'hui quand on pense à ce que peut
réaliser la mécanisation dans les
grandes plaines fertiles la culture de
ces champs inclinés ne semble pas
seulement anachronique mais absurde
seulement voilà comment dire à un paysan
qui peine toute la journée dans les
conditions les plus dures que son effort
est rigoureusement stérile à la limite
préjudiciable même comment lui faire
comprendre que sa fau sa serpe et sa
binette ne sont plus que des pièces de
musée du folklore et que ses vaches
comme celles des Indes sont devenu pour
l'économie du pays de coûte parasit
comment dire à un homme que le prix
qu'on P le fruit de son travail est une
charité déguisée par chance monsieur
gris l'avait déjà compris en attendant
que l'État lui propose d'autres moyens
d'existence il continuait avec sa femme
à produire un peu de tout et à vivre
chichement qu-ce que n monant Les géniss
à la montagne ah ben la semaine
prochaine il faudra pas pas manquer de
faire
l'échange monter Kti et descendre
Rosie cet après-midi on ferait bien
d'aller voir un peu les deux abondances
qui sont derrière le colléin oui Mo
encore assez de l'eau oui voir l'eau
puis le ouvrir le second parc pour
l'herbe parce que avec cette chaleur
l'herbe
diminue tu as vu les les chou ont repris
des
chenilles faudra poudrer encore alors
ouais bonjour messieurs dames alors vous
avez bien
dormi vous allez en promenade qu'zV
nous allons faire commission ah c'est
bien c'est bien et bien moi je m'envais
caché la cûe bonne journée ces gens-là
sont des touristes hollandais pendant
les vacances monsieur gris leur loue une
maison rurale qu'il a aménagé à cet
effet c'est l'un de ses principaux
[Musique]
revenus vous avez quel âge monsieur
grise et bien j'aurais 55 ans dans un
mois 55 ans oui et vous vivez ici à
pfolle sur combien d'hectares euh 6
hectares de terre labourable danst 1
hactare 20 et 20 de en location et puis
alors le reste est constitué par 4
hectares environ de prê de Foche ou
pâure ce sont plus de prê de Foche parce
que c'est en pin donc ce sont des pâures
des pâures surtout valables au printemps
vous combien de laitière qu qure vaches
laitières c'est variable 4 5 3 5 si vous
voulez ça fait combien de litres de lait
par jour actuellement oh actuellement
c'est près de 30 et vous pensez que pour
vous il y a un avenir dans
l'agriculture oh bien à mon âge il n'est
guerre possible de partir de parler de
d'avenir on maintient on fait tant qu'on
peut on a beaucoup de peine pour un pour
un revenu pour un résultat certainement
médiocre quoi vous savez voyez par
exemple nous sommes producteurs de
viande et bien nous n'allons guère à la
boucherie parce que pour nous elle est
est la viande est trop cherre seulement
se reconvertir à mon âge c'est difficile
ça pose bien des problèmes voyez à temps
perdu je travaille avec un charpentier
couvreur et bien malgré toute ma bonne
volonté je me rends compte que lorsqu'il
faut apprendre
c'est à mon âge 55 ans disonsle c'est
c'est difficile c'est difficile on sait
ce qu'on ce qu'on on pratique ce qu'on
mais pour améliorer c'est difficile si
l'état vous aide à partir c'est si on
vous donne une retraite et bien alors là
c'est c'est c'est envisagé bien sûr
c'est envisagé j'abandonnerai volontiers
ou bien de penser avoir un peu moins de
travail au point de vue agricole et puis
avoir quelque chose de plus rentable en
dehors en deh de l'agriculture vous êtes
jeune ça vous prend pas le cœur
d'abandonner euh si mais il faut se
faire une raison vous estimez donc que
vous avez moralement le droit de
demander de l'argent pour libérer la
France de de des excellents produit
laitiers oui je je l'admet très bien je
l'admet très bien oui monsieur gris est
prêt à jouer le jeu et à se convertir
mais les autres ceux qui sont en racinés
sur leur terre depuis tant d'années et
qui sarclle bêche bin encore à l'âge où
dans les villes on ne se fatigue plus
qu'à la pétanque ou à la manille bien
sûr c'est une question de temps déjà les
jeunes ont d'autres goûts des besoins
que leurs aînés n'ont pas une mentalité
différente plutôt que de s'acharner sur
des exploitations impossibles à
moderniser certains sont souvent prêts à
tenter leur chance ailleurs seulement
voilà où et pourquoi faire un exode
rural limité et nécessaire soit mais le
pays doit avoir quelque chose de valable
à proposer à ceux qui veulent quitter la
terre et puis il convient plus
d'aménager les campagnes que de les
déménager car il ne serait être question
de transformer la France en désert et
d'abandonner ses villages aux ronces et
aux Ortis libérer l'économie agricole de
ces excédents ne signifie pas arrêter
toute production il faut produire ce que
nous consommons pour ne pas avoir à
l'importer et être prêt à fournir la
demande étrangère de façon compétitive
le tout c'est de travailler dans de
bonnes conditions et de mieux organiser
la
commercialisation voici l'exemple d'une
première étape se grouper pour vendre
là-bas de l'autre côté du Rône au-delà
de la voute c'est la vallée de les Rieux
une petite vallée pittoresque du
département de l'Ardèche avec ses
vergers en timbre poste collé à fland
coteau autrefois c'était une vallée sans
histoire on produisait de belles pêches
et cela se savait là où il était
important que cela se sache au h à Paris
alors on les vendait facilement et à un
bon prix mais aujourd'hui des pêches il
en vient de partout de partout où le
soleil brille du gare du vaueluse de la
vallée de la Garonne d'Italie même
depuis le marché
commun même des gens d'ici ceux qui à
défaut de terre avaient un peu d'argent
sont descendus dans la plaine du Rône et
se sont mis à planter à planter des
arbres des milliers d'arbres oh bien sûr
les les petits arboriculteurs de la
vallée de l'air Rieux auraient pu verser
une larme sur le bon vieux temps les
faciles années d'autrefois et décourager
se mettre à la recherche d'autres
métiers mais parmi eux il y avait des
jeunes décidés à s'accrocher à cette
terre qu'ils aimaient il y avait Alibert
de l'arbre
gilbertlouis alors plutôt que de changer
de métier ils ont changé de façon de
travailler 120 d'entre eux se sont
réunis pour vendre tous leurs fruits
sous la même étiquette comme si toutes
ces pêches provenaient de chez le même
producteur afin que cela se remarque
mieux pour qu'on s'en souvienne mais il
n'y a que cette étiquette qui soit
commune c'est la limite du groupement
tout le travail de production se fait
séparément verger par verger en famille
avec le gamin et le grand-père comme ici
chez Monsieur Alibert le
président tout à l'heure monsieur Alber
je vous ai dit c'est un beau pays ici
vous m'avez dit un beau pays pour les
touristes mais pour quoi c'est pas un
beau pays pour les agriculteurs si c'est
peut-être un beau pays pour
l'agriculteur mais c'est le travail qui
est qui est un peu dur quoi est dur des
coteaux c'est des coteaux nous avons pas
de GAM de superficie oui vous avez
combien d'ectares vous 7 hectares je
vais vous poser une question là vous me
dites le travail est plus dur mais
est-ce que le supplément de travail est
payé ici jusqu'à maintenant non nous
espérons peutêtre qu'à l'avenir le
travail familial sera de nouveau
rentable c'estàdire qu'il y aura une
différ
vente par que ici le travail est fait
comme je vous dis en famille et la pêche
génal bien à point alors que dans les
gres expitations le travail par
É pas
connaissanceés pasême chezous vous vous
êtes Group vous avez créé un groupement
pour vendreos pêch
oui parce s'est aperçu qu' marché de R
la vente devenait plus difficile
c'est-à-dire que le commissionnaire
n'était plus intéressé par les petits
Doss qui se trouvaient par vous vendez à
la commission c'estàd que vous confie à
quelqu'un d'autre le soin de vendre pour
vous c'est ça en général la vallée toute
la vallée expédie à la Commission et
surtout sur
Paris après l'accueillette voici
l'emballage nous sommes dans l'atelier
d'un autre producteur de la vallée
monsieur de
l'arbre la planchette à trous qui se
balance au plafond sert à classer les
fruits par grosseur selon la technique
du passbou enfin en principe car ici le
calibrage se fait à l'estime au coup
d'œil tout ce petit monde va vivre sur
le kilo de pêche vendu au départ du
village c'est-à-dire tout emballé 60
centimes quand tout va bien à peu de
chose près la somme que le détaillant
là-bas à Paris prélèvera sur ce même
kilo simplement pour le distribuer parce
que lui aussi doit faire vivre sa
famille et que toutes les pêches qu'il
vend dans la semaine ne font guerre plus
que son propre poid ça n'est ça n'est
déjà plus de l'arbriculture ça c'est du
commerce oui vous conditionnez vous-même
tous les fruits que vous produisez sur
l'exploitation tous tous oui et ça se
fait comme ça dans toutes les
exploitations de oh dans toutes les
exploitations de la Vall de d'air Rieux
le conditionnement se fait en famille
c'est un conditionnement artisanal
et tous les moyens familiaux sont bons
pour arriver à nos bout je crois que
dans l'artisanat il est difficile de de
calculer un prix de revien au plateau
par exemple ou au 10 plateaux ou
ou sur une expédition pour l'emballage
pour le
conditionnement pour les abarculteur de
saintfortuna il n'est pas question
d'expédier à Lyon à Marseille ou à
Strasbourg encore moins d'exporter
toutes leur pêche prennent le chemin de
Paris via ringis Paris seulement car
c'est l'habitude depuis des années et
des années on connaî le transporteur le
commissionnaire est un ami alors
pourquoi changer changer oui ur n songe
pas ce train va beaucoup plus loin que
Paris mais il roule trop vite pour eux
il roule vers les grands marchés de
l'Europe des 6 vers Hambourg Bruxelles
ou Amsterdam il roule vers ses acheteurs
qui commandent par telx des tonnages
évalués par ordinateur il roule vers une
certaine façon de concevoir l'offre et
la demande ou plutôt la demande et
l'offre une conception qui ne s'appelle
plus distribution mais marketing car le
temps n'est plus aujourd'hui où l'on
peut mettre sur le marché ce que le
verger veut bien produire en comptant
sur les commerçants pour le distribuer
c'est-à-dire le faire disparaître par on
ne sait quelle
magie un arboriculteur moderne doit être
attentif à produire sur commande comme
il le ferait s'il était industriel il
doit cueillir le fruit vert pour celui
qui le veut vert il doit aussi arracher
ses arbres et en planter d'autres si ces
variétés ont cessé de plaire bref il
doit être prêt à s'adapter alors
seulement il créera des richesses qu'il
ne sera pas besoin de détruire de
stocker ou de vendre à
perte partout en France à la même heure
des milliers de paysans font les mêmes
gestes de la récolte ils les font sans
savoir le plus souvent ce que
deviendront les fruits de leur travail
s'ils seront acheminés vers les
consommateurs ou bien détruits c'est la
rançon un peu absurde de la division du
travail nous vivons dans un monde qui
dans son ensemble est sans doute plus
puissant mais où chacun prie
individuellement et chaque jour un peu
plus faible un peu plus isolé un peu
plus ignorant aussi du rôle qu'il peut
jouer de son avenir bien sûr le tribu à
payé au passé est lourd tellement lourd
qu'il risque de freiner quelque peu la
marche en avant du pays mais est-il
vraiment possible de progresser en
laissant derrière soi le 6e de ses
compatriotes l'agriculture n'est pas
seulement un dossier derrière les
chiffres derrière les constructions
intellectuelles derrière la raison
d'État il y a des hommes des paysans
qu'il faut rassurer et aider à devenir
fort en cet instant où après avoir
nourri la terre entière ils sont en
droit de se demander à quelle sauce on
veut les
[Musique]
manger